nous sommes aujourd'hui à tech'innove la
convention d'affaires organisé par la
chambre de commerce de l'essonne thédié
à l'innovation
c'est la troisième année que
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
paris saclay y participent
notre présence à cet événement est
naturel puisque naturellement nous
souhaitons attirer intéressé à paris
saclay toutes les entreprises innovantes
et nous souhaitons également collaboré
avec elle pour construire la ville
durable urbain scène c'est une toute
jeune start up créée l'année dernière
qui a vocation à augmenter la valeur
qu'elles soient économiques sociales ou
environnementales
la valeur des espaces publics paysagers
ou des espaces naturels à des fins de
tout simplement à réduire les coûts de
gestion associées à ces espaces ou
augmenter les utilisations possibles
qu'on peut faire dans cette négociation
la création de la ville sa compagne de
beaucoup d espace de paysages de
beaucoup d espaces verts
notre métier aujourd'hui c'est
d'accompagner la mise en place de ces
espaces verts et de fiabiliser le fait
que les végétaux vont bien pousser
correctement les premières années qui
sont les plus critiques notamment si on
parle des jeunes arbres des trois
premières années sont particulièrement
importantes pour la vie à long terme de
ces arbres et tout notre travail
aujourd'hui c'est d'accompagner
l'arrosage les soins qu'on apporte à ces
arbres pour assurer la croissance de ces
végétaux le territoire paris saké pour
une jeune start up comme mousse à la
fois une opportunité de faire des
affaires à court terme ce qui est
particulièrement important dans cette
phase de décollage et c'est aussi
l'opportunité de trouver des occasions
de faire les choses différemment trouver
des interstices d'innovation pour
déployer de nouvelles solutions et se
laisser le temps d'essayer des solutions
nouvelles
ça sent paraît particulièrement
important sur sa clé une ville durable
c'est une ville qui répond à l'ensemble
des besoins de ses habitants de ses
usagers mais c'est aussi une ville où
l'on consomme le moins possible de
ressources et ou le moins possible on
dépend des ressources des autres
ensuite nous travaillons à mettre en
valeur les énergies les potentiels
locaux notamment les énergies
renouvelables locales comme la
géothermie et enfin nous travaillons à
réaliser ce qu'on appelle le métabolisme
urbain c'est à dire à faire en sorte que
les déchets des uns deviennent des
ressources des autres ça concerne plein
de domaines ça concerne la gestion des
déchets le recyclage ça concerne aussi
le développement de réseaux intelligents
type smart grid énergétique pour
véritablement mettre en complémentarité
les besoins de
des usagers de la ville la vie ne sera
durable si elle soutient ce type
d'initiative elle fait pas tout mais
elle permet tout